okay in this video you're gonna learn
how to simplify square roots and cube
roots so we're simplifying radicals
we're gonna go through some different
examples here let's start off with
example number one so by the way if you
want to follow along with me and get
this worksheet I've got a link in the
description below to my teachers pay
teacher's store you can download this
worksheet it's got an answer key so you
can get some extra practice follow along
and you know benefit from that but let's
get into this video the square root of
20 is really what well to simplify the
square roots what you want to do there's
two different techniques one technique
is you can divide out perfect squares
and what are perfect squares these are
numbers like 4 9 16 25 36 etc any number
times itself and so in this case you can
see square root of 20 is actually like 4
times 5 what's the square root of 4 well
it's just 2 right and so we were left
with 2 square root of 5
now that's one method the other method
that students like to do and teachers
like to show their students is do a
prime factorization tree so what you
would do is you break down the number
into its prime factors but when you're
taking the square root what you're doing
is you're looking for two of the same
number it doesn't have to be the number
two it just has to be a pair of the same
number so for each pair for each group
of two numbers you get one of that
quantity so this would be 2 and then
you're left with five left over because
we only have one 5 here now if you want
to check your work you take the number
on the outside two you square it that's
4 and you multiply it by the number on
the inside and that gives you 20 which
is the original square root and you got
it so let's go ahead and do another
example but before I do that I just want
to give a shout-out to Brian mclogan
he's the one that put me in touch with
this notability app so that we can do a
little different type of tutorial here
to help you in your math class and help
you to understand these concepts better
so I wanted to appreciate Brian for
sharing that and go ahead and check out
his channel I'll put a link in the
description below so he's got a nice
format where he works with the students
in his classroom he videotapes it and
puts his lessons up on YouTube so if
you're looking for additional help go
ahead and check out Brian's channel and
let's go on to number 14 now so square
root of 108
okay so 108 what we can do is we can
break that
down into its prime factors so the way
we do that as we say okay this is an
even number because it ends in an even
number and you can see that that's going
to be two times 54 right 54 is even we
can divide that by 2 so that's 2 times
27 and 27 that's 3 times 9 and then 9
you can see is 3 times 3 right but
remember we're looking for groups of two
of the same number so here's a group of
two here's a group of two and we've got
a three left over so we've got for each
group of two we get one of those so
that's going to be 2 times 3 ok which is
6 and then you can see how we have this
3 over here left over we want to put
that underneath the square root okay now
what would happen if there was a 3 left
over and like a 5 left over well then
you would multiply those together and
that would be 15 underneath the square
root okay so that's just the prime
factorization method let's go down to
another example how about for example
like number 6 see if we can do that one
okay so we've got the square root of 98
over here
okay so 98 you might recognize that 98
is the square root of 49 times the
square root of two because 49 times two
is 98 49 is a perfect square so we could
write that as 7 root 2 so that was kind
of an easy one but when the numbers get
a little bit larger like let's say for
example number 17 the square root of 392
right well 392 let's do the prime
factorization method for this one so 392
we know it's even we can divide it by 2
so that's gonna be 196 times 2 if you
can't do that in your head just use a
calculator this is going to be 2 times
98 this is going to be 2 times 49 and 49
is 7 times 7 okay so we're looking for
groups of two we've got a group of 7s a
group of twos and we've got a 2 left
over right so this is going to be 7
times 2 which is 14 and then this 2 this
left over that's gonna stay underneath
the square root sign and we've got it 14
square root of 2 okay so you're with me
so far let's go ahead and cruise on down
to some cube root examples how about
number 20 so we're taking the cube root
of 56 and by the way you know it's a
cube root because you see that little 3
right there that's called the index
and that tells you you're looking for
perfect cubes okay to factor out so what
are perfect cubes those are numbers like
eight because that's two cubed okay here
let's write that down two cubed and
let's see what else do we have we've got
27
that's three cubed we've got 64 that's
four cubed and so on so you can memorize
these and that's definitely helpful or
you can do the prime factorization
method which I'll show you in a moment
but first of all let's go ahead and
break this down so we can see this is
eight times seven right now the reason I
picked a it again is because that's a
perfect cube and the cube root of e is
two and so you can see we're left with
two and seven left over so two cube root
of seven now again if you don't like
that method which a lot of students
really really don't care for this method
this can be a quicker way of doing it
but if you're not super keen on that
just go ahead and break down the number
into its prime factors okay like I'm
doing right here now and remember when
you're taking the cube root you're
looking for groups of three of the same
number right so let's see we've got a
group of three twos here so that
represents a perfect cube so that's just
going to be two and just get one of that
group and then we've got a seven left
over now if there was a seven and a two
left over you'd multiply those together
and that'd be 14 underneath the radical
and again if we had another group of
let's say threes then we would multiply
two times three that be six on the
outside so you're trying to make groups
of three right okay let's do another
example let's see if we can cruise on
down to number 23 okay so this one's the
cube root of 144
okay so cube root 144 let's do the prime
factorization method so we know 144 is
12 times 12 okay from our multiplication
facts right so 12 is 4 times 3 12 is 3
times 4 and then these fours we can
break down into 2 times 2 but remember
we're taking the cube root so that means
we're looking for groups of three right
so let's see there is a group of three
okay so that becomes 2 but look what we
have left over we have left over a 2 a 3
and a 3 so we want to multiply those
together we don't have enough to make
another group of three of the same
numbers so these are like kind of the
leftover the remainder 3 times 3 is 9
times 2 is 18 the 18 stays underneath
that radical and you've got it okay so I
hope this video helps you to understand
how to work with square roots and cube
roots and simplifying them again if you
want to download the worksheet go ahead
and check that link out in the
description below and I've got an answer
key so you can check your work otherwise
I look forward to seeing the future
videos let me know in the comments below
what you thought of this particular
format if it was helpful of course I'm
going to continue to do the regular
whiteboard videos that I've been doing
but again my goal is to help you to
boost your score in your math class
improve your understanding and hopefully
make learning math a lot less stressful
and so that's what these videos are all
about so if that's helping you let me
know and I look forward to seeing you in
the future videos